on voit ça vous arrange mais à leur
grande surprise aujourd'hui c'est que
y'a un nouveau avec avant un beau but
international luxembourg qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est dur là il faut qu'on
fasse des recherches pour voir si c'est
quelqu'un vraiment qui a déjà tenu le
milieu médical que s'y connaît on va sur
un signe du vert de la relève pour
savoir avec qui parce que le mal nos
pratiques monsieur niveau européen parce
qu'ils s'engagent à 90 boussens s'engage
à 98 vous savez c'est dur on récupère
vatican d'une remise pratiquement
puisque quand on fait une analyse le
goût cabba ne sera pas dieu poussant ça
veut dire qu'ils sont minoritaires pour
ne pas dire ah ça vous sent alors on va
chercher à savoir vraiment parce que
c'est une nouvelle équipe une séparation
coups fourrés ou pas mais on va savoir
parce que d'après ce que j'ai entendu
on va analyser quel montant qui va
relancer et nous fera le tour de la
chaîne une autre côté attend l'europe et
pour savoir s'il va pas se retrouver
piégé à nouveau parce que le bouc a pas
ça fait treize ennemis qui sont là une
veulent pas lâcher le morceau se voyant
difficultés de la dernière ligne droite
maintenant je cherche à la rescousse de
l'europe honneur au niveau international
qui sont des gens qu'on ne connaît pas